esports are built on relationships
from coaches and players to content
creators and fans
these relationships plus incredible
skills in game
is what makes esports such an enjoyable
pastime but sometimes
these relationships extend way beyond
friendship into something more
yes i am talking about the bromance
today we wanted to take a look at both
some of the names in esports who've
reached bromance status with one another
as well as the beauty behind a couple
bros just
being bros here are the top 10 bromances
in esports
opening today's list we have the
unlikely bromance between
two league of legends kings tyler1 and
faker how is yours
good hi steve we are basically best
friends
their friendship began in 2018 when the
biggest pro and biggest content creator
in league
first met at all stars taking a now
iconic photo together but over the last
few years the two broke through
language barriers and distance creating
one of the strangest
and funniest friendships in league of
legends
oh wait i think i'd have token it i got
you dude call me a muscle
what wait and in case you think it's all
an act
tither one has faker on speed dial
that's right tyler1 knows faker's phone
number and you don't
hello tyrone hey bud how you doing man
you look pretty good you too
nothing is ever quite like your first
crush and that's why our number nine
entry is a relationship
that can only be described as love at
first sight
anivia and froggen in lane she's really
a nuisance not to mention
that's dragon hovering over olivia what
can you pick maybe you'll actually win
team fights here i don't think there's
anything i knew i did
anivia was froggen's first main champ an
idea he picked up from his brother
i don't think you could let this in 2010
because my brother played a lot and
he introduced me to it funny part is he
was also in an interview one trick at
the time so
it's just like natural for me to go in
and in the dear maine too
and once he went pro frogging quickly
made a name for himself with his
favorite bird
and the problem for gambit oh i'll tell
you what god that's what we're used to
seeing from
froggen just controls him with the wall
the stun
it all comes out and one fluid motion
it's been years
and while anivia has gone in and out of
the meta froggen has
never let her go still busting her out
whenever he can and looking as
deadly on the champ as ever
in this 4v4 looking at the next round
the flash in they're gonna find the stun
that was beautiful from froggen
even when he's not playing anivia
froggen can't stop
talking about this champion almost a
decade since he began playing
and the dudes still got the bird on his
brain
next on our list is overwatch's premiere
bromance
kareev and agilities oh
it was hard there yeah such a hard day
because i view my team
no you kareev and agilities began
playing together on immortals midway
through 2017
eventually transitioning to the orgs
overwatch league team the los
angeles valiant and it's there that
their bromance blossomed
i don't want to get bitten you want to
try
it's not okay
overwatch fans loved watching their
antics including their famous gamer
snacks series
today we are making hamburgers
cheeseburgers or cheeseburgers
and in 2020 bands breathed a sigh of
relief
when the two announced they continue
playing together on toronto defiant
even getting to continue making funny
food videos with the new organization
skip the dishes
let's go tonight why because
why tomorrow okay tonight yeah
although they're no longer playing
together in 2021 their bromance
continues to live on
i mean just look at twitter
coming from the world of call of duty
esports we have the t2p duo at number
seven
otherwise known as skump and formal the
dynasty
not only are skump and formal both
all-time greats in call of duty but they
are one of the most beloved duos the
game has ever seen
uh i have some candles over here because
i do like you know
waking up with some nice scents that's a
big uh that's a big thing to me smell
these
he loves his music his tv shows
[Laughter]
sure they had a rough patch at one point
which some people might call
beef there was like a competition sort
of within the team
and once we started losing i feel like
that competition kind of like just ate
away at the relationship because
you know he wanted more of the
recognition or whatever or i wanted more
recognition
whatever it was but that beef is ancient
history
last year the pair teamed up again and
they reminded
everyone why we loved them in the first
place
at number six is the most beautiful
romance in cs go
kenny s and the op manages to get out of
this post position picks up the frag
onto aloo
goes for the quick second shot forest is
causing
oh my goodness so much damage done here
by kenny yes another fright found out
again
kenny s kenny s is the best opera of all
time and if you disagree
well we've got plenty of clips to prove
you wrong
let's see how he handles it and he was
expecting the flash as he ends up just
getting humiliated staring at the wall
kenny
he's looking for more and this is
phenomenal stuff
he finds another one man he's he's
already gone above and beyond
flashes looks like he wants some more
rops is on those close boxes he does
drop in and kenny
he's doing it all it's katie yes baby
when you think of kenny s you think of
the op
all right kenny as a ct what do you do
with you eliminated all the teas but the
bomb is planted i've saved the l
it's gem time i mean the dudes even got
the scope tattooed on his arm
it might just be a man loving a fake gun
but
it's as real as bromances get
our next bromance comes from the best cs
go team
ever i'm talking about astralis device
zip x and dupree
device do you think super will ever be
the main offer for astralis
no i doubt he will be the auburn any
team in the world
to be an unprecedented dominant force in
cs go like astralis has these last few
years
a team needs to have chemistry on and
off the server
luckily for astralis device zipex and
dupree
have that in spades you have no idea
which is my favorite movie
i have like i have a good guess but
inception you're so close
ah that was the one i meant but i
i seriously meant
when you think about it it makes sense
these guys have played together for
eight years
across five organizations i think that
how we as a team were like together
at that point it was when we started
like hanging out constantly and had a
lot of good memories
and you know how the old saying goes
bros who stay together
win four majors together
if you're a long time n a league fan
there's probably no bot lane closer to
your heart than
double lift and afro move aka rush hour
holy [ __ ] oh what's going on
i was all tad man
that [ __ ]
on the rift double lift and afro move
were unstoppable
in the front lines dexter there as well
elimination gets hooked up by aphromoo
he goes down two kills a double if the
alt comes out sneaky has nowhere to go
triple kill for doublelift
and off the rift they couldn't stop
making each other laugh
rebound yeah or bound what is that
uh it's the new hip way of saying
rebound
that's i i was getting the rebound and
that's how i feel my pinkies
yeah and together they became lcs
champions and now taking down team solo
made its madison square garden
to be your 2015 summer split
champions but at the end of 2015
that bromance met its end after afromoon
clg
kicked doublelift from the team we used
to be friends back in the past but since
coming into this new roster iteration
that we had for summer split i valued it
more to
bring everyone else to the level that we
were at and i spent more time with them
than i did with peter
so that definitely damaged the
relationship of course
and then going into this off season we
just didn't
really agree and the organization wanted
to part ways with peter
don't worry though time heals all wounds
especially in league i'm sorry i should
did you just try to rub his nipple with
the
point to the rocket mortgage never mind
there are few rosters in league of
legends that are as
beloved as the rox tigers they were just
a bunch of pals who happened to be on
one of the best league teams
in the world top and hip has been killed
and they even got the pick off on bang
rox doesn't actually have to stop
pushing right now they can delay the
recalls
look at the teleport
dude which means they can push it's now
on wall it's intelliver coming in
for snap and girl how much more can be
done
this is not gonna be enough it's not
rocks tigers
are back with game two
i love this series
the team formed as a squad of misfits
and captured viewers hearts
with their incredible play amazing
uniforms
and silly antics
[Applause]
[Music]
although the team parted ways at the end
of 2016
the bromance continues to this day at
the end of 2020 they even had a reunion
after smeb kuro and gorilla retired
four years later and these guys still
can't get enough of each other
in the runner-up spot on today's list we
have the tragedy of dota 2's greatest
bromance
that's right it's fly and no-till
no tail and fly you could ask anyone in
esports
this is the ultimate friendship these
are two guys
that have just stuck with one another
thick and thin throughout different
rosters different years different teams
even
the two started their esports careers
playing heroes of new earth together
before transitioning into dota 2. the
way me and tal
met was in a public game we were playing
almost every day
like either practicing or just pubbing
or whatever so
we ended up talking a lot all the time
you know it's like a brother to me
fly and no tail played together for
years
but even after they split once fly got
kicked from team secret
their friendship remained strong so
strong that they decided to make a new
team together
oh gee team og was formed by myself
and no-till the big idea behind og is a
mindset of friendship
but also want to win together they won
four
majors turning og into one of the
biggest names in dota
they fight all the way through the lower
bracket and will be cleaned the
champions
of the first ever dota 2 major live here
in frankfurt
but in 2018 seeking bigger prize pools
fly blew it all up by leaving for evil
geniuses
we lose and then we we go back to the
hotel
and uh well we just got called into a
room
and i learned that the two players are
leaving
and one of them's my best friend fly's
departure only energized no-till
who turned his lost love into pure skill
winning back-to-back ti's after fly left
even dunking on his former teammate in
the process oh gee with the fortitude to
stick through it after
dealing with such important defining oh
the look there from
mozart topping today's list
is an esports bromance that spans over a
decade across
multiple games and teams forest
and get right what is my favorite type
of music
baby baby
justin bieber the duo's relationship
started in 2009 in the cs 1.6 days
when get right in forest first teamed up
on fnatic
any second get right will spray and
fnatic will win the intel extreme
masters global challenge
here in dubai after a thrilling game
there against meet you makers
from that point forward the duo were
inseparable they left fnatic for sk in
2010
and then transitioned to cs go together
joining ninjas and pajamas
there they made history beginning their
journey into cs go
with an 87-0 map streak
by 2014 they were major champions
there is nothing they can do any longer
nip
have won gamescom 2014 ladies and
gentlemen
16 13. it finally happens
but fans didn't just love them because
of their skill if you put a camera in
front of forrest and get
right something funny always happened
boost me
here boost me in elo
boost my elo get right is finally
retired now while forest is still going
strong
but their friendship has lasted for
years
and you've gotta believe it can last
forever
alright guys that is it for our list of
top 10 bromances
what did you think did we miss an iconic
duo let us know in the comments below
if so also you should probably subscribe
to the channel already if you haven't
and hit that notification button so you
know exactly
when our new content goes live now i
won't see you next time
but danny burke certainly will it's it's
i i have a few different bromances but
the
the one that our audience is probably
the most familiar with and you guys on
this call is
keith capstick we go back years at this
point and it is
certainly a love-hate relationship that
you guys have experienced in other end
boards
i would also brendan i would say that
like you she-hab and
andrew and and me all have like a
four-way bromance
you know we got we kind of got all that
going i wouldn't use the word for away
you know